what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I'm back at it again to
discuss the new insane one-piece
spoilers since you guys enjoyed last
week's video so much and since we will
probably be at Peak Luffy and Peak
fiction for at least the next few
chapters this is going to be another
Banger chapter actually dealing with the
main battle and how it progresses it
continues right where we left off last
time and it does not go on some random
tangents that nobody cares about so make
sure to stay tuned for that if you do
enjoy these one piece videos I want to
keep them coming you know what to do
channel the piricking within and smash
that like button with no mercy remember
smashing is pirate king energy and
passing a scared Orochi energy so choice
is yours if you haven't make this video
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
like this one and this is the worst
possible time to be missing one piece
just saying now a quick thank you to
boxu for sponsoring this video booksu is
a premium Japanese snack box
subscription service that delivers
original assortments of Japanese snacks
and tea pairing right to your door every
month you receive a new box with a new
theme and the snacks are always
different this month is special because
it's time for cherry blossoms boksu has
put together snacks and tea pairings
sourced from all over the country that
will allow you to experience Sakura
season in Japan just take a look the box
is packed with all sorts of limited
edition cherry blossom themed snacks
anyone who subscribes to boksu during
the month of March will receive Sakura's
season as their first box so subscribe
Now link in the description Japan is
known for its amazing snacks and with
books too you get the best of the best
they're the only Japanese company that
partners with 100 plus year old family
snack makers to deliver exclusive
Gourmet snacks right to your door this
is not the kind of stuff you can find at
just any store I have a Japanese store
in my hometown and I love it but booksu
is on a different level this is
exclusive authentic and Gourmet Japanese
goodness every single month these are
not just snacks this is an experience
trust me it's so worth it that use my
code Upper 10 to get 10 off save up to
47 your own authentic Japanese
subscription from boxu don't miss out on
this delicious snack journey through
Japan Link in the description now let's
get into It spoilers and all so we left
off with the biggest chapter ever last
time Luffy awakened his fruit which was
not the gomugomunomi but actually the
human human fruit mythical model Nika he
called this Awakening gear 5 and oh boy
was it thrilling Luffy was exhilarated
and that really came through to us
reading the chapter another detail is
that Luffy is Sun God Nika Android boy
at the same time now and sunnisha
recognized him as such his Awakening
brought greater physical strength to his
robbery body and greater freedom in
seemingly every sense it was labeled the
most ridiculous power with not one but
two exclamation marks he used this
ridiculous power to pull a fresh prince
on Yoko kaido he smacked him around for
a while pulling him up from the ceiling
as if it was the the hand of God coming
down he yanked this gigantic kaido up
like he was dealing with a toy snake
some important aspects were that Luffy
seemed to go to world which is a
reference to Yu-Gi-Oh but also Looney
Tunes Not only was he himself governed
by more Looney Tunes logic than ever he
could make things and people around him
more cartoonish as well when he was
dealing with kaido kaido's eyes were
popping out of his head Luffy gained
Popeye muscles he had his own eyes pop
out in ridiculous fashion and he even
rubberized the ground and used it to
create a rubber wall that launched
kaido's attack back at him he was
laughing all the time and even though
I'm making it seem like Luffy wrecked
kaido to be fair kaido was actually glad
that Luffy was alive at the end of the
chapter and near the end after all that
damage kaido still seemed fine solid
Like a Rock first name Chris I'm just
saying his recovery was really good it
definitely deserved an Oscar so Luffy
got to show off his new insane powers
and the chapter was filled with the
euphoria of that but kaido is still
standing in this chapter we might need
to come back to earth but let's find out
like last week these spoilers are coming
from Oro Japan one chapter 1045 is
called Next Level a very hyped title
because even though we got a new form
this suggests we are getting another
level on top of that and spoiler alert
we do get that in a way as we'll see so
gotta hand it to Oda he's spoiling us
with epic moments lately it's just epic
moment after epic moment we get a new
color spread of the straw hat gang which
we don't see here in the spoilers
they're sitting together and we see the
phrase sea of Liberation I love my color
spreads and I'm excited to see nami's
outfit as always really looking forward
to that we're told the whole chapter is
the Battle of Luffy vs kaido which I'm
so glad about I'm so glad we didn't just
catch up with the other characters here
no we're sticking to the main event it
is a very fun battle we're told very fun
being emphasized we're told we will be
able to enjoy it a lot more when we see
the images compared to the summary or
spoilers which yeah totally makes sense
so just based off of this I'm expecting
much more of the tune World stuff that
was introduced in chapter 1044
continuing here because what else could
very fun be referring to except Luffy
obviously laughing the whole time like I
said Luffy's probably going to have a
crazy good time going along with the
whole Joy boy thing and probably bending
a bunch of rules that we have taken for
granted up to this point as someone who
likes to get lost in specifics I can't
wait to see what other crazy Powers
Luffy will use in this very fun fight
tunifying himself kaido and the ground
itself were all pretty crazy last
chapter so I'm sure this one will have
similarly crazy moments I'm wondering if
Luffy will get a Kamehameha type attack
here or down the line to match kaido's
blast breath and also his new fiery
Saiyan like hairdo kaido says to Luffy
that his fruit is very unusual it
transforms his surroundings into rubber
like a paramecia but also transforms the
user like a zone so nothing new here
he's just clarified buying what we saw
last time with the ground but he'll
probably be transforming the environment
a lot more in this chapter too which
might be what causes Cairo to say this I
believe Sawyer actually mentioned in one
of his reviews that zunisha might have
super long legs because the joy boy of
the past kusunisha was confirmed friends
with made zunisha's body like that and I
think that makes a lot of sense so far
we just saw kaido's eyes popping out and
return to normal but it's totally
possible that Luffy can use his powers
to permanently change others just like
ivankov's power can remodel a human from
the inside and the change will just stay
unless he changes them back in this case
that would explain how zunisha got the
way it is and the possibilities of this
power are pretty horrifying to be honest
but that's obviously not the direction
One Piece would take it in it'll be more
funny than anything but I'd assume it's
at least theoretically possible he could
morph people in a way that they couldn't
fight back well anymore not that he'd
want to do that or win like that since
that wouldn't be as much fun anyways
then we're told Luffy uses a new attack
act which I think is the new level that
the title was referring to because it
sounds more like a new form than just an
attack he calls it gomugomo no gigant
which just looks like it's referencing
giant which answers the question people
were wondering about namely no he won't
stop using gomugomu in his attack names
or change the names of old attacks as
far as we know Luffy still doesn't know
he has the Nika fruit unless I'm missing
something so this totally makes sense
it's still the same Luffy with the same
knowledge just stronger and more capable
in his view this is gear 5. anyways as
it sounds with this attack he uses his
fruit powers to become a giant he
transforms his whole body into a giant
one and we're told he looks like a god
wow that image is going to be insane and
yeah just when he mentioned he's at his
Peak Oda immediately is like nah let me
show you how he surpasses that in the
next chapter this form will be
interesting because he kind of looked
cartoonish and not too serious in the
new gear so far so this god-like giant
body might be the cool looking gear 5 we
wanted to see as I was making the one
piece video rounds I also heard and I
think it was from O'Hara a theory that
Luffy would be able to turn into a full
Giant and thus the giant Straw Hat we've
seen will take on new significance and
yeah that's exactly what seems to happen
here the old Joy boy if he wasn't a
giant was probably in this form quite a
bit or maybe always and hence the giant
Straw Hat was a clue to this eventual
form for Luffy he's grown into the old
Joy Boys giant shoes metaphorically
except it's a giant hat instead of shoes
I don't think Luffy will maintain it all
the time or even most of the time but
still it was a cool clue of what was to
come and this is exactly what I wanted
to see a bunch of creative forms
spreading from gear 5 just like gear 4
had multiple forms so even if we don't
get more gears which I think we won't we
can still look forward to seeing Luffy
use this one in creative ways and
specifically use using it to come up
with cool new forms that serves a
purpose at hand since kaido has one of
the biggest Zone Transformations it
makes sense that Luffy would make
himself bigger to match it too it must
be quite the sight actually seeing these
two in their giant forms I can't wait to
see everyone's reaction to this form
we're told Momo and Yamato reach the
roof and see this new form but we don't
get their reactions from the spoilers
and you're probably thinking this is too
good to be true and as if to agree with
you Oda has Luffy run out of energy here
but it's not the end Luffy continues to
defy his limits and he gets his heart
pumping blood again with the drum sound
that zunisha recognized as the drums of
Liberation and by doing this Luffy
recovers I have a feeling after all this
Luffy is going to have some Zorro level
recovering to do but we'll see I fear
that he is eating away at his lifespan
as he does all of this the sun is
powerful think of escanor and his son
powers in the seven deadly sins I feel
like it will be a Luffy burning through
his lifespan kind of thing to use this
godly power but again we'll see Luffy
will definitely become pirate king it's
just a matter of what will happen after
that and part of me is thinking he'll
follow and Goldie Rogers footsteps but
he's the protagonist of a Shonen so I
may well be wrong let me know what you
think the cost if any of using this
godly power will be in the comments at
the end of the chapter Luffy punches
kaido in the face man you just know
that's gonna be an epic panel I can't
wait to see this he may no longer be in
his giant form here it's not clear in
the spoilers but I'm hoping we see him
throw some giant God punches imagine how
much that would hurt even kaido may get
a concussion eventually with all those
God punches coming at him Luffy says
this is very fun isn't it kaido and
quote and the spoilers don't let us know
Kato's condition or anything is he
looking more exhausted or is he as fine
as ever but that's cool since it gives
us something to look forward to I think
we can all agree though kaido has been a
great antagonist a great opponent and
Oda has shown him respect worthy of the
strongest creature in the world the dude
has been taking beating after beating
and he was fine even after taking year 5
attacks last chapter he seemed fine and
happy to see Luffy alive Oda really
knows how to deliver satisfying boss
battles there's no doubt about that but
that is it for this one hope you enjoyed
it and obviously look forward to the
full translated Pages review later on in
the week there will be plenty more new
stuff to talk about if you did enjoy
this video and want to see more like it
you know what to do Channel pirate king
within and smash that like button with
no mercy remember smashing is Joy Boy
energy and passing his sad kaido energy
so Choose Wisely if you haven't make
this the video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and this is
the worst possible time to be missing
one piece I must say and lastly while
you wait for new updates and chapters to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on all yonko Warlords Supernova Admirals
all fruit users all mythical Zone users
specifically and so much more link to
that is description by the way also
check out my new Blackbeard video I
really enjoyed making it I think you'll
like it and until next time see ya Space
Cowboys